poser les fondations d'une europe plus
souveraine après le choc de la vision
russe en ukraine c'est l'objectif des
dirigeants de l'union européenne réunis
à versailles la guerre déclenchée par
vladimir poutine a souligné le manque de
capacités militaires européennes réduite
depuis la fin de la guerre froide
c'est un moment déterminant pour
l'europe à ce sommet de l'on repensé la
défense européenne avec des capacités
forte nous allons repenser l'énergie
angie
l'énergie
la grande question de ce sommet la
guerre en ukraine a mis en lumière
l'extrême dépendance énergétique à la
russie des pays de l'union européenne
malgré l'adoption d'un paquet de
sanction inédite lieu continue de
financer la russie qui fournit plus de
40% de son gaz naturel et 27% de son
pétrole l'europe elle doit se préparer à
être indépendante du gaz russe à être
indépendante pour assurer sa propre
défense à être indépendante en terme
justement d'approvisionnement de ses
marchés mais les 27 restent divisés sur
le refus de toute importation de pétrole
et gaz russe la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen a déclaré sur twitter que lui et
dorée cesser d'ici 2027 d'avoir recours
aux énergies fossiles en provenance de
la russie ajoutant qu'elle soumettrait
mi mai un plan pour y parvenir
l'adhésion à l'union européenne de
l'ukraine devrait également être évoquée
kiev avait déposé des candidatures dans
l'espoir de la rejoindre sans délai pour
l'heure les chefs d'état ont exclu une
adhésion rapide tout en ouvrant la porte
à des liens plus étroits avec le pays